[Music]
to talk more about what happened in
westminster this week i'm joined now by
michael patello the former conservative
mp and broadcaster who himself ran for
the tory leadership in 2001.
michael thank you for joining us this
week on spectator tv um as as we speak
to one another uh we're hearing the drip
drip of no confidence letters slowly
trickling in a handful this week
is the situation terminal for boris
johnson
no i don't think it is i think his
position has probably improved quite a
lot over the last few weeks
a combination of circumstances the
opposition to him in the conservative
party is disorganized and divided
i think some of them have been quite
spooked by some of the tactics of the
whips and some of the things that have
been uh written about them
i think he was very much helped by the
defection of a tory to the labour
benches
i think he was helped by what david
davis said a couple of weeks ago in the
house of commons because david davis
managed to get the tone of it wrong
but i suppose most of all he's been
helped by the fact that the
sugray report is coming out in drips
and so it's very difficult for a tory mp
who wants to make a decision about
whether to get rid of boris johnson or
to know quite what when that moment is
because there's a sense that we ought to
wait until the whole process is
completed well that may now be weeks or
i think more probably months
and there's always the feeling that not
all the information is there yet
and in the interval the alternatives
have been on display rishi sunak liz
trusts i'd say a few others
and i've not been overly impressed by
them in the last few weeks i dare say
tory mps haven't been either so remember
they're not just deciding whether they
want to get rid of boris johnson they're
having to think about who might be a
better replacement after the long and
bruising business of choosing a new
leader because if boris goes there'll be
a lengthy leadership election because
the conservative party procedures
are really not designed for a
conservative party in office and
although they've now been used
repeatedly when the conservative party
is in office but they're inappropriate
for it so one way or another i'm not
saying that boris will survive but i
think his chances of survival are pretty
good and i think they're a good deal
better than they were
and
one of the things that's been dominating
the conversation in westminster in
recent weeks other than cake uh is
confidence votes it's yet to happen but
as you as you mentioned and we're in a
situation where no one's really
organizing the letters she feels it's
dripping it's various parts of the party
so it's very hard to predict but if we
end up in a situation where 54 letters
go in and there is a confidence vote do
you therefore think boris johnson is
actually quite a strong position to win
that vote or could a secret ballot come
back to bite him
well i'm not in the house of commons
anymore i'm distant from it and
you can only know that if you're in the
house commons and indeed even if you're
in the house commons you can't know that
because you can't know everybody's mind
you don't know what's going to happen
you don't know what can be the impact of
a brief election campaign around the
vote of their confidence you know i
think boris would get in touch with a
lot of members of parliament he would
use his famous charm so there are all
sorts of unpredictable things but with
all those caveats i would have said yes
he has a pretty good chance of surviving
the confidence vote
um if teresa may survive the confidence
vote
i think boris has a pretty good chance
although things have moved on a lot
since the last election
there must be some conservative mps who
remember that they won the last election
with brexit and with boris now brexit
will not be an issue in the next
election or certainly not in the way it
was at the last one and then they have
to ask themselves can they win next time
without either brexit or boris
now you encourage margaret thatcher not
to resign um and i wondered
if you were speaking to borrow shots and
now it's perhaps it's what you were just
saying there about um what mps could be
thinking or maybe should consider what
do you think boris johnson should be
saying to his mps to make them focus
their minds
well the most important thing is to say
something to them and i mean on a
one-to-one basis
that the reason i urge margaret thatcher
not to resign
after all the members of her cabinet had
urged her to quit
was that in the brief
leadership election campaign
she had not canvassed a single member of
parliament she hadn't asked a single one
of them to vote for her the campaign was
handled by others or rather mishandled
by others and so my point to her was
she was still in the race at that stage
and i thought that if she canvas hard
she could still um hold on
now i don't think boris needs this bit
of advice because he's rather good
at canvassing people but the second bit
of advice apart from talking to people
that i would offer him
is something that i gained from michael
hesseltine and hesseltine's principle
was that no member of parliament was a
lost cause was a hopeless case so even
if you know that somebody has opposed
you for decades that's no reason why you
shouldn't go and canvas them because you
don't know
whether that person will calculate that
keeping you boris is a better bet than
the alternative
as an example of this in a way
i probably spent 20 or 25 years
uh hoping and even mildly campaigning
that boris should not become the leader
of the conservative party and here i am
now rather believing that if i was still
a conservative member of parliament i'd
probably want to retain him rather than
lose him at the moment
um now you're a low tax story and one of
the things which has been interesting to
follow in the past week or so is boris
johns had lots of meetings with his mps
doing some of the things that you you've
just been talking about you know
telling them why they should stick with
him and repeatedly the national
insurance hike has come up and many mps
as i think tends to happen in a boris
johnson meeting left with the distinct
sense that the prime minister agreed
with them and was going to ditch it but
we heard over the weekend from rishi
sunek and boris johnson that the
national insurance rise is going ahead
how much of a problem do you think is
that for boris johnson's position if
tories ultimately feel that he is
not uh as leading the conservative
government they want to see and perhaps
the next election is going to have
talked about more big state conservatism
than what they would want to
well i think they're going to be very
unhappy that national insurance is going
up
some of them a few brave souls actually
voted against it and the reason they
voted against it was not just they
didn't want tax rises but in particular
they didn't want that tax rise they
didn't want a tax that fell on working
people quite heavily
and they didn't want tax that fell on
jobs quite heavily
and on employers and that could have an
effect on putting up prices
and the combination of all that with the
other things that are going to happen
the general uh inflationary position and
the energy prices it's it's a serious
situation and um members of parliament
are very worried that they're going to
lose
heaps of votes
about all of this
the um the comparison with margaret
thatcher is quite interesting
because
she probably
for a while at least
talked about a game than the one that
she played i mean i was just checking
this today you know the rate of income
tax the top rate was 60
until 1988.
that is to say that she had been in
office for nine years with the top rate
of tax of 60 percent top rate of tax
today i believe is 45
so
of course it depends what you're
measuring and i believe that it is true
that the tax burden is now at its
highest for 70 years so this is
displeasing to tories
on the other hand if you're going to
make historic comparisons it's probably
best to you know make them quite
accurate and to me i mean it is
extraordinary to recall that we were
there nine years in government with the
top rated tax of 60 percent
so perhaps um boris johnson and rishi
sunik have a point when they say they
have thatcher rights still
um
i i i i don't i don't think they are
that's right but
i think rishi
sunak perhaps is being saturated in a
slightly different way
which is he said as chancellor that he
was going to increase spending on
um social care and on the national
health service in particular the
national health service and that it
would have to be paid for
that there wasn't a magic money tree
well of course there has been a magic
money tree but the
magic money tree has come to an end
that's his position and for his
credibility as chancellor it would be
very bad i think if now it could be said
oh yes where all these increases can be
can be uh paid for and the taxpayer
doesn't need to bother to recompense
these chequers it can all go on
borrowing now margaret thatcher was a
bit of a stickler for trying to reduce
public borrowing and rishi therefore is
showing some that right tendencies in
wishing to control
the amount of public borrowing
now i want to talk about the point you
made earlier which is ultimately one
thing is keeping boris johnson safe
right now is if we think about who could
replace him no one's really sticking the
head over the pads that you had tom
teugenhat i'm saying he will run if
there's a vacancy um but no one in
cabinet and
you uh managed your own challenge for
the leadership of the party in 2001.
what do you think will be going through
the minds of um you know would-be
contenders you mentioned university
sooner than liz trust when it comes to
when to make your move how to operate
where why by perhaps you look loyal
while also keeping your chances there
well i think they'll be wondering
whether there is any dignified way to
indicate to the world that you'd be
willing to lead the conservative party
whilst also telling the world that you
are absolutely loyal to the existing
prime minister
and the fact is that there is
there is no dignified way of doing that
i think rishi sunak made a pretty good
error right at the beginning of this
when he was very slow to indicate
support for the prime minister and did
so in a pretty half-hearted way
on that first day liz trust was pretty
slow but she's since become
apparently a very fulsome supporter of
uh boris johnson as leader of the
conservative party
no they they are in a bind um tom
tuggenheit is in a much
easier position he can declare his hand
he has declared his hand
the the thing that um tom trigger hat
would have to fear because i've made
both of these mistakes so
one mistake i made was being in the
cabinet and trying to indicate to people
that if john major left i would be ready
to stand
but the following time which was 2001
the one you referred to
and i declared my candidacy very early
because i didn't want a reputation for
hesitancy
and then for a couple of weeks maybe i'm
exaggerating but there were no other
candidates and i was hanging there the
only target so in all that time all the
fire was directed at me
so tom is somewhat in that position
being a declared
prospective candidate
he does offer himself as a target for
criticism and for indeed character
assassination because things get pretty
nasty in the tory party
and on that i mean the tory party does
have a reputation for being registered
but some have been querying that
recently and asking about the tory party
has lost its appetite what do you think
well i don't think the tory party
actually has an appetite for regicide
it's just that you know every now and
again it deems it
necessary i mean obviously i wasn't in
agreement when they deemed it necessary
in the case of margaret thatcher
when they deemed it necessary in the
case of theresa may i thought it was
massively overdue
but
the decision i think i may have said
this already
is not of course just whether you want
boris johnson or not but whether you
think that someone else would do better
i think it's a very tricky decision
because
things look pretty bad at the moment
it's difficult to imagine with the anger
that people feel about partygate
that they have forgotten it in three
years time
but three years time is a very very long
time i think it is quite possible
that at least they won't feel the rage
that they feel now well maybe maybe
they'll maybe they'll have turned
against boris and they won't turn back
but you can't rule anything out because
when the electors go to the polls
presumably the choice is going to be
boris johnson or kia stammer and i think
the chances of boris beating kierstarma
are still pretty good so these are
complex calculations that conservative
members of parliament have to make
maybe boris's greatest fear should be
the following that quite a lot of
members of parliament don't have much
experience
not only because they came in in 2019
but they've not been in a collegiate
situation
for most that time because of covid
so they're they're quite they're quite
uh raw they're quite immature i mean for
example i hear people talking about how
bad the local election results are going
to be and how terrifying that is but it
isn't because the local election results
are normally terrible for the government
and very often governments have done
extremely well afterwards i i remember
meeting boris johnson to interview him
the day after the european elections of
oh my goodness what was it 20
2019 wasn't it when um the conservatives
had come fifth
and got nine percent
but later that year six months later
would win a general election with a
majority of 80. so you know the
electorate make decisions about how to
vote and understand perfectly well
they know that a local election is quite
different from a general election and
they may well vote very differently i i
think on the other hand
if i've seen the the latest polls which
put labour five points ahead i mean five
points ahead is historically quite a
small margin for the opposition party
when the government has been through a
rough patch which it certainly has
and do you think in order for boris
johnson to
keep support of those mps who decided to
stick with him for the time being
does he need to change how he governs
because one of the big frustrations is
the fact that number 10 often seems very
dysfunctional and that leads to bad
choices and new terms
well of course he ought to change the
way he governs i mean i i think the
shambles at downing street is absolutely
disgraceful and uh and unrecognizable
from anything i've ever seen um in the
past
so of course he ought to govern better
and he ought to reorganize
he ought to become more serious as a
person he ought to become more
interested in understanding the
decisions that he takes
and not for example in the case of
partygate thinking that because he
didn't much like the decision
that he had announced that probably one
way of showing his his contempt for his
own announcement was to ignore the rules
that he was imposing on others
so of course there ought to be
improvements but when i heard him say
in the house of commons
i've got it and i'll fix it
that to me was wholly incredible and i
think will be to the vast majority of
conservatives so of course he ought to
change but i very much doubt whether any
of them is placing a bet on the
likelihood that he will change
and just finally um michael gove is your
biographer he wrote that you were the
future of the right and i think in turn
uh you once said that he was the future
of the right um do you still think that
uh i doubt it i mean it
no one's talking about michael gove at
the moment as a future leader which of
course might turn out to be to his
advantage
what what i do know about michael gove
is that he is um in many ways an
absolutely model minister
uh you know he he stands out uh head and
shoulders above most of his colleagues
because when he gets to a department he
has an idea about what he wants to do
and he gets it done um
so you know i think he's a very very
strong
candidate for prime minister
unfortunately he's made many enemies uh
along the way and so i don't anticipate
that that will be what will happen but
in terms of ability uh michael
uh probably would be
um the strongest candidate
i remember that's not all that tory mp
is worried about they're also worried
about
who can win elections so boris's
inability to be
certainly a conventional i would even
say an effective prime minister
is
for some members of parliament at least
secondary to his proven ability to win
one election after another
if he can keep his ratings uh going the
right direction i suppose turn those
ratings around um thank you very much
for joining us today michael
[Music]
you